Let's take a moment to meditate on the fact that this code, like many
class patterns in Java Script, has two distinct and very different sections.
This will be true of every pseudo classical, prototypal, and
functional shared class that you write.
One section, you will find specifying how all the instances of
a class should be similar.
In the case of the pseudo classical pattern,
these similarities are generally stored as properties of the prototype object.
In the other section, you'll be writing code that specifies how
each instance should be different from all the other instances.
As with most programming languages, this will take place inside the body of
the Constructor Function, and it'll allow us to specify how one instance of
the class will be different from another instance of the class.
All of the work that gets done to specify that Amy and
Ben have unique locations is done inside that Constructor Function.
For now, this is just an interesting observation about classes, but
knowing that these two categories of code exist for every class will
become very important later when we start to discuss subclassing.
Looking back at the functional version of this class for
a moment, it's also interesting to notice that functional classes without shared
methods make no such distinction.
In this style, all the code for both categories appears in one place.
The similarities and the differences across instances appear here,
indented two spaces inside the car function.
Depending on your perspective, you could call this an asset or
a failing of the functional pattern.